Bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
nous allons parler d'auto-organisation
et de comportements collectifs.
Petit message préventif...
Des physiciens de bordeaux ont étudié le
comportement de petit cafards mécaniques
comme celui ci...
Ce sont des jouets pour
enfants en plastique muni de dix petites
pattes molles et d'une petite batterie.
Leur corps vibre, ce qui engendre un
déplacement globalement en ligne droite
avec de petites variations de direction.
Les chercheurs ont étudié comment
s'organisait un groupe de plus en plus
grand de ces petites bêtes mécaniques
lorsqu'on les place dans une enceinte
fermée de 60 cm de diamètre.
Exactement comme des cafards coincés au fond de votre poubelle.
Lorsque les cafards mécaniques sont peu
nombreux ils bougent dans tous les sens
et ne s'accumulent pas.
Ils adoptent ainsi un
comportement que l'on qualifie de gaz.
Oui, un gaz de cafard mécanique.
Hé bien j'aurais jamais cru dire un truc comme çà.
Disons qu'ils se comportent comme les
molécules dans un gaz.
Mais quand on augmente le nombre de
robots-cafards un étrange phénomène se
produit :
Regardez..
Dans cette expérience on en a 120,
soit deux fois plus que dans la première vidéo.
Alors qu'au centre
on observe bien toujours l'agitation d'un gaz,
on voit que certains se massent,
bien alignés face à la paroi.
Vous trouvez pas qu'il y a un petit côté
malaisan
même si on sait que ce ne sont pas des vrais blattes ?
Donc à partir d'un nombre critique de cafards mécaniques
70 environ
on observe une transition vers un régime stable
ou deux états coexistent.
le gaz,
les cafards au milieu,
et les agrégats : Les cafards autour de la paroi.
Et cette observation est en accord avec leurs théories
comme on peut le voir sur cette
simulation.
Ceci est un modèle purement informatique
du comportement de particules
de même taille et de même vitesse que nos cafards mécaniques.
Elle se déplace globalement en ligne
droite avec des variations aléatoires
à gauche avec 60 particules et à droite
avec 120.
Et maintenant si on lâchait les cafards ?
Lorsqu'on place des cafards dans une enceinte mobile et flexible
ils forment très vite des agrégats
même avec seulement une dizaine de cafards.
Ces agrégats poussent la paroi
et permettent de la déplacer et ils
arrivent à traverser un trou.
et même contourner un obstacle.
Allez vas-y, dégages !
Mais non allez, laisse moi entrer !
Je rappelle ici qu'il s'agit de jouets mécaniques
sans communication entre eux
et sans aucune coordination globale.
Je sais pas si cette réflexion rend la
chose plus rassurante ou plus flippante.
Ces recherches montrent donc l'émergence
d'une auto organisation à partir
d'éléments indépendants très simples
et ce type de dispositif ouvre la voie
à de nombreuses applications dans le
nettoyage ou l'exploration
car les mini robots arrivent à se déplacer
entre les obstacles
et dans des espaces très étroits.
Par exemple il pourraient
accomplir des tâches comme la
dépollution au milieu dangereux.
Voilà donc je vous laisse sur cette note positive
parce que on peut le dire
cette recherche
elle ne donne pas  cafard.
Salut  Max ça va ?
Ah ouais c'est trop bien
je reviens d'la poubelle de Zeste de Science
Ha c'est trop cool
Ha ouais ?
Ouais vas-y abonne toi
Ouais d'accord
j'vais m'abonner.